[Music]
in the 13th century Genghis Khan
embarked on a mission to take over
Eurasia swiftly conquering countries and
drawing them into his expanding Mongol
Empire with his vast armies he became
almost unstoppable but legend has it
that there was one obstacle that even
the impressive Khan couldn't overcome a
towering wall of ice grown by locals
across a mountain pass to stop the
Khan's armies from invading their
territory no one knows how historically
accurate that particular story is but
remarkably it draws on fact for
centuries in the Karakoram and Himalayan
mountain ranges people have been growing
glaciers and using these homemade bodies
of ice as sources of drinking water and
irrigation for their crops but before we
get to that fascinating phenomenon it's
important to understand the difference
between glaciers that grow in the wild
and those that humans create in a wild
glaciers require three conditions to
grow snowfall cold temperatures and time
first a great deal of snow falls and
accumulates cold temperatures then
ensure that the stacked up snow persists
throughout the winter spring summer and
fall over the following years decades
and centuries the pressure of the
accumulated snow transforms layers into
highly compacted glacial ice
artificially growing a glacier however
is completely different at the
confluence of three great mountain
ranges the Himalayas Karakoram and Hindu
Kush some local cultures have believed
for centuries that glaciers are alive
and what's more that certain glaciers
can have different genders including
male and female local glacier growers
breathe new glaciers by grafting
together for marrying fragments of ice
from male and female glaciers then
covering them with charcoal wheat husks
cloths or willow branches so they can
reproduce under their protective
coverings these glacier Rhett's
transform into fully active glaciers
that grow each year
additional snow fo those then serve as
lasting reserves of water that farmers
can use to irrigate their crops these
practices have spread to other cultures
where people are creating their own
versions of glaciers and applying them
to solve serious modern challenges
around water supplies take Lada a
high-altitude desert region in northern
India it sits in the rain shadow of the
Himalayas and receives on average fewer
than 10 centimetres of rain per year as
local glaciers shrink because of climate
change
regional water scarcity is increasing
and so local people have started growing
their own glaciers as insurance against
this uncertainty these glaciers come in
two types horizontal and vertical
horizontal glaciers are formed when
farmers redirect glacier melt water into
channels and pipes then carefully siphon
it off into a series of basins made from
stones and earth villagers minutely
control the release of water into these
reservoirs waiting for each new layer to
freeze before filling the Basin with
another wave in early spring these
frozen pools begin to melt supplying
villagers with irrigation for their
fields local people make vertical
glaciers using the meltwater from
already existing glaciers high above
their villages the melt water enters
channels that run downhill flowing until
it reaches a crop site where it bursts
forth from a pipe pointing straight into
the air when winter temperatures dip
this water freezes as it arcs out of the
pipe ultimately forming a 50 metre ice
sculpture called a stupa shaped like an
upside-down ice cream cone this inverted
form minimizes the amount of surface
area it exposes to the Sun in the spring
and summer that ensures that the mini
glacier melts slowly and provides a
reliable supply of water to feed the
farmers crops
these methods may be ancient but they're
becoming more relevant as climate change
takes its toll on our planet
in fact people are now growing their own
glaciers in many regions beyond a Lada
Swiss people utilizing modern glacier
growing technology created their first
stupa in 2016 in the Swiss Alps there
are plans for over 100 more in villages
in Pakistan Kazakhstan and Kyrgyzstan
perhaps one day we'll be able to harness
our homegrown glaciers well enough to
build whole walls of ice this time not
for keeping people out but to enable
life in some of the planet's harshest
landscapes as Nikola Tesla said the
progressive development of man is
vitally dependent on invention check out
this playlist to see some of the
ingenious inventions giving us hope for
a brighter future
[Music]